audiences have come to expect three big
things from Game of Thrones wild plot
twists a fair amount of bloodshed and
gorgeous costumes spoiler alert the
series finale included the
characteristic trio and placed an
unexpected emphasis on the last of the
three during the closing montage of the
Game of Thrones finale viewers watched
as Sansa Stark prepared herself for her
coronation as Queen in the north now a
completely separate Kingdom with its own
ruler it was a full-circle moment for
Sansa and the outfit she wore featured
several tiny details that paid tribute
to her incredible journey here are all
the hidden meanings behind Sansa's final
game of Thrones look the first nod to
Sansa's evolution from a meek girl
wanting to marry Joffrey Baratheon to an
independent woman who would do anything
to protect her family is found in her
intricate test plate Game of Thrones
costume designer Michelle Clapton
explained that the bodice features the
growing branches of the weirwood tree
the tree important to the stark family
found in the godswood of Winterfell
within the series plenty of pivotal
moments happen beneath the weirwood tree
Nights Watch recruits making their vows
Jon Snow reuniting with Arya and Arya
killing the night king once and for all
the weirwood tree is a place of worship
for House Stark that Sansa's coronation
dress features its branches is quite
special the chest plate itself is also
significant in that it shows a softer
side of Sansa she sported armor before
but this is more delicate worn for peace
and not war speaking of the weirwood
tree one of the two belt sleeves of
Sansa's dress is embroidered with deep
red five-pointed leaves the same ones
found on the sacred tree in the novels
written by george RR martin weirwood
trees are said to live forever if they
are properly cared for and left
undisturbed this is seemingly what Sansa
intends to do with the north preserve it
so that it may never fall not only do
the leaves on Santa's costume honor
House Stark but they also provide a
drastic contrast to her younger self who
desperately wanted to be a southern
Queen and not a northern girl they also
show that she is finally in the exact
place she was
meant to be moreover they linked to her
brother's recent inauguration as king of
westeros and to the attitude of the
north as a whole the sleeves themselves
are symbolic as well as they and Sansa's
entire dress are made from the same
fabric as two other iconic Game of
Thrones outfits Clapton revealed that
she utilized the fabric from the dark
Sansa dress seen on the 8th episode of
the fourth season when Sansa unveiled
her mysterious new look to Littlefinger
shall we go that dress was made using
the fabric of the costume Margaery
Tyrell wore when she married Joffrey
when she lived in King's Landing
Sansa went to great lengths to blend in
with the southern women around her and
took a particular interest in Margaery
who tried to help Sansa escape the
Lannisters viciousness Sansa also wears
a feathered embroidered direwolf stole
around her neck and across her shoulder
as a tribute to House Stark
Clapton noted that Sansa sleeves are
textured with the same feathers and fur
as the stole to top everything off is
Sansa's crown an intricate ring that
meets in the middle to show to
direwolf's howling the crown symbolizes
Sansa's dedication to her family and to
the north and even looks similar to the
crown Cersei Lannister wore in her later
years when she sat on the Iron Throne
Cersei taught the stark girl many
lessons not the least of which regarded
what not to do when you rise to power be
a good wife to him you'll see I'll be a
queen just like you I promise I won't
touch anything the crown rests atop
sonses fiery hair worn down and without
any braids or twists her hair in this
final look sends an impactful message
about what she's been through and where
she intends to go all throughout her
life Sansa has worn her hair in styles
of varying complexity each of which was
meant to mimic the people whom she
wanted to be like son says humble braids
during the first few episodes of Game of
Thrones showed that she was a northern
girl her wild updos during her years at
King's Landing emulated Cersei Lannister
styles her pulled back braids reflected
the style her late mother used to wear
the heavily braided style seen on the
later episodes of the series evokes the
dews daenerys targaryen war with each
braid indicating a battle won in the
Dothraki tradition have you seen those
Dothraki dudes they can get it everybody
on that show can get it wearing her hair
loose and unadorned shows that Sansa
isn't trying to be anyone else other
than herself and a few fans have even
drawn parallels between Sansa's
coronation hair and that of real-life
Queen Elizabeth the first
both women faced abuse throughout their
lives and both opted for coronation
hairstyles that held deep significance
cultural critic and expert on
Renaissance literature anthony oliveira
said in an interview with Fox that Sansa
quote learned the same lessons as
Elizabeth and the two women channeled
their changing power through their
physical appearance he explained when
it's time for Elizabeth's coronation she
wears her hair down which is a big big
deal it signals her virginity to be
unadorned for her is the ultimate
adornment the showrunners have been
building this throughout Sansa is a
seamstress she loves embroidery she's
learned how to be image conscious that
was Elizabeth's game like costume
designer Michelle Clapton said nothing
is created without meaning every aspect
of santa's final look was significant
and they all came together to create a
lasting image of the person she was
destined to become the aspiring queen of
Westeros is now the Queen in the north
and long may she reign check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about Game of Thrones
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bells so you don't
miss a single one
you